[Music]
welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber big news Monday in the
long-running feud between actress Amber
Heard and her ex-husband actor Johnny
Depp you likely remember their
defamation cases against each other
which captured the nation's attention
for weeks well Amber Heard announced
Monday that she has reached a settlement
with Johnny Depp where she will pay him
one million dollars now in February 2019
Depp sued herd over an op-ed that she
wrote for the Washington Post in which
she claimed that she was the victim of
domestic violence heard then
counter-sued and in the end jurors
returned to more than 10 million dollar
judgment against herd while giving her a
separate two million dollar judgment in
her favor because of Depp's attorney
calling her claims a hoax heard vowed to
appeal that is until the settlement
Depp's legal team says that he plans to
donate the million dollars to charity
heard said in a series of Instagram
posts that she's not making any
admissions that she did anything wrong
but rather sees this as the only way out
of a bad situation Nation long crime
followed this trial from beginning to
end bringing it every moment of
testimony as well as of course the
Monumental verdict
to use what I've lived through and and
and and and what I've survived calling
it fake
saying that that I'm I'm harming
Johnny with this I'm harming the public
with this
is what I've lived through and to to say
that it's a hoax that these aren't even
real things also I hadn't even
spoken about the sexual abuse within my
marriage
I hadn't
I had been protective of that I didn't
want to talk about that ever I had to go
to another country to give testimony and
thankfully they allowed me to do so with
confidentiality and some protection
and then Johnny through his lawyer
not only uses that against me but says
it's a hoax
as against Amber Heard we the jury award
compensatory damages in the amount of 10
million dollars
as against Amber Heard we the jury award
punitive damages in the amount of five
million dollars all right so I'm here
with my co-host Brian buckmeyer and
Terry Austin Brian will start with you
one million dollars down from more than
10 million does that seem right to you
and by the way what happens if she
continues to make defamatory statements
now Jesse I think that Johnny Depp is
playing chess not Checkers and asking
for the million dollars because don't
forget it's less than two million
dollars that Amber occurred supposedly
one not supposedly one actually one in
the case so the question now becomes are
you going to try to collect on that 2
million when he went down from ten to
one and of course he's always said this
is not about the money it's about
clearing his name and I think this kind
of proves that now if she continues to
make defamatory statements he can again
file suit against her I think that's
probably why this case got settled and
that's why he's trying to handle it the
way that it is he's trying to look
magnanimous here yeah I don't think
anybody wants another trial and there's
no gag order he's probably like just say
what you want to say Terry
in the bigger context the settlement the
entire Saga how's that going to impact
the metoo movement and women who want to
bring these types of claims well I've
just got to say I am grateful that this
did settle I mean we had the UK case we
had the U.S case we had her potential
appeal so it's a good move but I think
the metoo movement is going to survive
this was a little bit damaging as far as
me too is concerned in fact they put out
a statement right before the verdict
saying that this has been misused and
that it's actually harming the women
that it was designed to protect but I do
think that there are safeguards in place
I think this jury did not believe this
witness but I do believe other jurors
will believe other Witnesses so in other
words this is a very unique situation
maybe don't use it as a test for
everything else that would come down in
the pipeline well jurors in the sexual
assault trial for disgrace movie Mogul
Harvey Weinstein are in their 10th day
of deliberations this comes after a
recess Thursday and Friday the journey
return to the Los Angeles courthouse on
Monday now Weinstein is charged with
seven sexual related counts involving
Four Women four other women testified
that they too were assaulted Weinstein's
defense team says that some of the
assaults were simply made up While
others were consensual sexual
relationships or transactional in other
words that the women might get a part in
a Weinstein movie for example Court
officials confirmed the jury has asked
for some readback of testimony but most
jury Communications are being quite kept
secret we asked judge Brandon Birmingham
who presides over a district court in
Texas why he thinks it might be taking
the jurors so long to reach a decision
he told us it could have something to do
with all the attention the trial is
getting
maybe they've already got decisions that
are made and they are you know just
gonna try to go over it I I do know
having done a lot of research on the
Jack Ruby trial that um that's what the
jurors did they actually came in they
took a vote in the four person withheld
his vote even though he wrote in his
book later that he was going to vote
guilty because he didn't want it to be
too quick he didn't want to give the
impression that in a large trial a big
trial nationally renowned trial like
that that the jury just sort of skipped
over everything and didn't even consider
it so maybe there's something like that
too Timothy mcveager said the same thing
and even in trials that are not so high
profile and nationally renowned like
that you know the jurors want to give
everybody there they're sort of due
diligence and you know I hear
prosecutors or or lawyers defense
attorneys too saying hey you know vote
for guilty or vote for not guilty this
shouldn't take more than five minutes
and all that but I don't think jurors
really appreciate that because of the
the weight of the decision whether it's
easy or whether it's hard
now all that is happening out on the
west coast you might recall that
Weinstein was already convicted of rape
in New York and he was sentenced to 23
years in prison
well we turn now to the University of
Idaho quadruple murder case Moscow
police now say more than ten thousand
tips have come in since the four
students were brutally stabbed to death
in November in newly discovered
surveillance video two people believed
to be victims Kaylee Gonzalez and Maddie
Mogan are seen walking in downtown
Moscow hours before the killings in the
video a woman could be heard asking
Maddie what did you say to Adam she
replied like I told Adam everything
while many online have jumped to Adam
being a suspect Kaylee's father Stephen
Gonzalez told Fox News that that person
is not a suspect the video was posted to
a Facebook group dedicated to the case
the person who shared it said that they
had submitted the video to police but
thought getting it out to the public
would be more helpful police have said
repeatedly that they will only release
vetted information that does not hinder
their investigation
over now in Texas we're following the
trial and conviction of former Fort
Worth police officer Aaron Dean the jury
is deliberating in Dean's penalty phase
the ex-officer was convicted of
manslaughter last week in the 2019 death
of a Tatiana Jefferson Jefferson Dean
went to Jefferson's home after receiving
a call from a concerned neighbor about
Jefferson's doors being open late at
night as Dean walked around the outside
of the property he shot and killed
Jefferson through her bedroom window
sentencing began right after Dean's
conviction and more evidence was
presented from both sides before closing
arguments on Monday the defense said
Dean's family is receiving death threats
in fact a man was arrested and escorted
out of court on Friday for making
terroristic threats to the family the
judge addressing Friday's arrest said
quote my goal is to protect everyone as
for Mr Dean he faces between two two and
twenty years in prison and welcome back
everybody a college in Ohio has finally
finished paying a local bakery after
publicly calling them racist a judge
ordered the school to pay 2 25 million
dollars plus 11 million dollars in
interest in attorneys fees Gibson's
Bakery and Food Mart took matters into
their own hands after a student from
Oberlin College stole a bottle of wine
in 2016. Alan Gibson the bakery owner's
son Chase F chased after and tackled the
student leading to a fight when two
friends got involved they later pleaded
guilty to misdemeanor charges and
because all three accused in the
shoplifting shoplifting incident I
should say were black Oberlin college
students decided to protest outside of
the store in fact according to court
records School administrators even
handed out flyers at one of the protests
and those flyers called the bakery a
quote racist establishment with a long
account of racial profiling and
discrimination so what did the bakery do
while the bakery sued the school for
libel and they won Oberlin College
appealed the case to the Ohio Supreme
Court which declined to take up the case
so Terry it took nearly six years for
the bakery to get out their payout is
that reasonable when you factor in the
entire appellate process us you know it
is reasonable at least in this instance
it's a long time but it makes sense
first of all the amount of the verdict
was so large that any losing party is
going to automatically appeal that and
even though the Ohio Supreme Court
declined to hear the case the appeal
process is very lengthy with briefing
schedules arguing schedules and those
deadlines are often pushed back and on
top of all of that obviously the covet
pandemic caused a backlog of cases in
courts around the country some of those
courts are just now clearing their
backlogs and remember this was a small
family-owned business that lost a lot of
money because of the statements made
against it you can't just recklessly
claim an establishment is racist unless
there's evidence to support that claim
and the bakery is finally getting the 36
million dollar payout which they say is
Bittersweet after all of this time you
know just we are seeing multiple
defamation cases today with big payouts
including the Johnny Depp case we talked
about and the case against Alex Jones I
think people are finally taking these
cases far more seriously Bittersweet I
like that that was a nice touch talking
about a bakery Brian is there a lesson
here for libel you know for the college
and maybe people in general yeah I think
Jesse it kind of piggybacks off of what
Terry is saying if you're going to make
an accusation make sure you can back it
up I I get it is there profiling when it
comes to young black men going into
stores yes that exists in many Avenues
but it seems here based on this lawsuit
it didn't exist in this Bakery and I
think the school made the problem of
getting involved if this was just a
protest with the students and they chose
not to go to this to this Bakery then
that's them but the school getting
involved and not having all the facts
and not arguing it the way they should
have you can see here they're paying 36
million dollars and that's a lot of
bread
uh yeah how do I compete with that I
mean I can't even come up with the unfly
like a cupcake rest it's that's the
whole cake piece of cake you guys you
guys are too good I don't know what to
say Brian Terry thanks so much everyone
out there thanks for joining us here on
Long crime daily we're gonna see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America